for many months reports have shown the
business is desperately trying to fill
positions on the other side those who
are applying say they're not getting
calls back kate houston stopped by job
fest today a job fair put on in part by
the state to speak two attendees trying
to find work
major strip resorts and casinos were
just one industry trying to fill those
positions and overall attendees were
eager to speak to hiring managers in
person saying it's been difficult to
navigate as they newly enter or re-enter
the job market 23-year-old jessica henry
works in food service and is looking for
a new or second job but it's taking
longer than expected it's been kind of
tough to do it out on my own i've been
applying to other places i either get a
response or just kind of reaches a dead
end ideally henry wants to find
something to make a career out of
something more sustainable because i
enjoy my current job but
it's temporary for sure as henry just
enters the job market nicholas samuel is
now re-entering it i recently came off
of reserve orders
my job that i had wasn't available
anymore so now i'm trying to find a new
career and something that's going to
take me for the next 20 years or so
samuel is hoping it won't take more than
six months but notices things have
changed since the last time he had to
apply for work a lot more competition
education everything is definitely a
bare minimum of a standard
so trying to find something with just
work experience isn't you know the
minimum anymore kate houston live local
now